we know CBS News senior national
security contributor Michael Morell for
his more than 30 years at the CIA where
he served as both deputy director and
acting director but did you know that he
is also a podcast very good one too it's
called intelligence matters Morel talks
to a leading voices in national security
and foreign policy they tackle issues
like counterterrorism cybersecurity and
negotiating with adversaries and what
lessons these experts learn through
their careers the first episode of the
new season is out today
it features morels conversation with
Michael Hayden former director of both
the CIA and national security agency the
podcast is produced by CBS News and was
initially done in partnership with the
cypher brief website Michael good
morning good morning so on the podcast
you get to tell all the secrets you
couldn't tell what are you hoping to
achieve with the podcast so what we want
to do is have a place where you can have
a discussion about national security
issues where there are no politics you
know it used to be true that politics
ended at the nation's shores that
politics didn't get involved in national
security issues that's not true anymore
so we want to have a place where we can
talk about those issues that's that's
where there are there are different
views but people aren't scoring
political points this is a slightly
abstract question but it's something we
deal with in the press too which is
there is intelligence that you can get
wrong in good faith and that's part of
the job and then there is the history in
the intelligence agencies where
sometimes people cooked things and where
politicians took the information and
cooked it is that one of the goals here
to try to put things in their different
categories so people understand the
difference between a mistake mistake
made in good faith and something that
was said that wasn't exactly I'll give
you a great example there is a
misperception right that the Bush
administration politicized the judgments
about Iraq having weapons of mass
destruction just not true the CIA and
the intelligence community believed that
even before President Bush came to
office we were telling President Clinton
that so that's a great example and you
had a fascinating conversation with
Michael Hayden who was on this show this
week about Gina Haskell right in the
controversy surrounding her nomination
to be CIA director and you raised a
question about whether or not there was
a double standard going on with regards
to her nominee
and talk about that what I meant by that
is that you know there were hundreds of
CIA officers who were involved in this
program and they were all told that
President Bush told accurately that
President Bush directed it the national
security team approved it the enhanced
interrogation of the enhanced
interrogation / also known as torture
also known to some people was torture
right that the Department of Justice
said it was legal that it was not
torture and that Congress was briefed
those officers were told that then the
politic shifts right and all of a sudden
it becomes something we shouldn't have
done should those officers who worked in
that program be held accountable for
something that the leadership of the
country made the decision to do and the
double standard comes in the following
sense the the Senate confirmed John
Brennan who was the number four in the
CIA when the program was conceived and
approved now he wasn't in the chain of
command but he wasn't in number four and
he opposed the program and he spoke up
at the time but he still was in the
chain of command he was confirmed the
military had its own enhanced
interrogation program after 9/11 we
never we never talked about the military
officers who were involved in it and
whether that should be part of their
confirmation hearing well both of you
worked with Dina Haskell at the CIA and
Michael Hayden says this her track
record is honesty candor and courage yet
it doesn't appear she's going to have an
easy time of it when her confirmation
hearings begin so people have two
questions right they have this question
about should somebody who was involved
in the program lead the CIA and my your
answer is yes my answer is yes for her
my answer is yes in part because she
went through it she went through it once
right and because of that she'll she'll
make sure that the agency never does
that again and if the agency's ever
asked to do anything that she's
uncomfortable with she will say no
because that courage is in her DNA as a
CIA officer is that the larger question
though is when does act of conscience
even when you've been ordered to do
something I mean this has been a
longtime debate in these kinds of jobs
that that act you should take an act of
conscience if you've believed something
you've been ordered to do is wrong and I
think that's one of the questions she's
going to have to answer at her
confirmation hearing it's a fair
question and it was interesting that
Michael Hayden said if she had been
appointed
by President Obama she would have gotten
through so politics does have a play at
a place here quickly let me ask you your
thoughts on what for resented by Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu on the
findings they made in Iran's nuclear
program what did you make of it so first
first there's nothing new here in 2007
11 years ago the intelligence community
told the White House in Congress that
Iran had a secret nuclear weapons
program prior to 2003 that it stopped in
2003 so there's nothing new here in
terms of the big picture there may be
details here in the intelligence
community's got to figure that out that
helped our understanding of what they
were doing at the time
that that may be the case what what what
really happened here was an Israeli
prime minister who was trying to
influence an American president and an
American public would be more supportive
of an American president who's about
ready to pull out of the Iranian I think
he was successful I think President
Trump was headed in that direction in
any case we'll see about the public
reaction he did deliver in English /
Hebrew he sure did like we're all great
to have you on and I love the podcast
thanks for being back thanks the latest
episode of intelligence matters is
available now on major podcasting
platforms new episodes will be released
weekly